Grab your Ashley Too dolls...
(These are not dolls, Jim)
...and contain your excitement, because we have an all-new season of Black Mirror.
In this video we'll be looking at season five's episode three: Rachel, Jack and Ashley Too
--which is the origin story for Hannah Montana
(not really, thank God)
So get ready, as we'll be taking a deep dive into the ending.
And if you want to skip ahead just to the Easter eggs, I posted a time stamp in the description below.
To better understand the ending we have to rewind to the beginning.
Unlike traditional Black Mirror stories, which tend to follow one character, this episode follows three.
It's so important the name of the episode is literally named after those three characters.
Now, you might think that Rachel is the main character here.
After all, we start on her, spend most of the beginning with her, and the narrative is largely pushed forward
by her obsession with the Ashley doll, but I'll go over in a bit why I think that's not the case.
Rachel's starting at a new school and doesn't have a lot of friends.
She's lonely not just because of her lack of friends, but she's lost her mother, too.
She lacks confidence, and when someone asks her whether she's gonna sign up for the talent show, she says "no".
But Rachel's defining feature is her obsession with pop star Ashley O
a woman who seemingly has the perfect superstar life, and in Rachel's mind is something she wants to become.
She practices her dance moves, listens to all her songs, and asks her dad,
who doesn't even know it's her birthday coming up, to get her an Ashley Too doll.
And part of the reason Rachel loves Ashley so much is her positive message and outlook on life.
Her lyrics are upbeat and empowering, saying things like "you're on a roll"
and "you're gonna get what you deserve".
As Ashley says in her interview:
"it's really important for people to feel like they're in control of their own destiny...
"and, you know, that means having the confidence to be who you want to be".
The irony here is that Ashley herself isn't in control of her destiny;
she's trapped in this fake world pretending to be something she isn't.
She lives in a glass house, just like one of Kevin's mice,
and is controlled by her domineering manager/aunt, Catherine.
If that isn't clear enough, she composes her own music, writing "see the animal in the cage you've built".
While talking to the janitor at Rachel's high school, Kevin explains the inhumanity of poisoned mousetraps,
and how they kill these creatures slowly.
Ashley's poison is her medication, from her aunt, which slowly eats away at her too.
She yearns to be free, which is best personified when she stares longingly at the rock-and-roll venue.
Like Rachel, Ashley has no friends. They are oddly both similar and dissimilar at the same time...
But back to the mice analogy.
It doesn't stop at Ashley; both Rachel and Jack feel trapped, too.
Rachel is trapped in a new school, unable to make friends,
while Jack is trapped in the past, unable to get over the death of her mother,
and unable to muster the courage to play her guitar for others.
As Rachel says, "sure, ever since she died all you do is mope around with that stupid guitar,
"which you're probably no good at 'cause you're too scared to play in front of anyone".
It's here that I think Jack shifts is the real protagonist of the story.
You see, Rachel wants to have friends, and to be able to muster the courage to perform at her talent show.
She achieves both of these about halfway through the episode, although not in the way we'd expect.
She fails miserably at the talent show and her only friend becomes a robot.
Not to mention that Rachel is fairly passive in this story;
things happen to her instead of her making things happen.
Her character, when compared with Jack and Ashley, changes the least by the end of the episode.
But let's look at Jack's arc.
Jack wants to get over the death of her mother and to find her own place in the world.
She even reads Jim Dodge's "Stone Junction", which is a coming-of-age tale
in which the protagonist tries to find his place in the world.
But the whole getting over the death of her mother is personified through her
gaining the courage to play her guitar at the end of the episode.
Not only that, but the irony of her playing alongside the woman she made fun of her sister for adoring
is not lost on us.
But Jack is more of a protagonist simply because she propels the story forward with her actions.
For example, she hides the Ashley doll, steals her dad's van, and
smashes Dr. Monk in the back of the head with a tray.
Jack hides her grief in music, rock-and-roll, septum piercings, and dark clothes.
A contrast to Rachel who prefers light upbeat pop with empowering messages.
At the end of the episode, her journey has brought her on stage with Ashley
and she is finally playing, moving on with her life.
But it's Ashley's character who goes through the most visible arc.
She's a woman who, quote, feels like she's wearing someone else's skin,
trapped in version of herself which isn't who she is.
In fact, the part of her that her aunt likes, the one that's great at doing press junkets and interviews,
constitutes only four percent of her brain.
Which leads us to the main part of the story: the rise of Ashley Eternal.
When Catherine learns she can no longer control Ashley, she takes matters into her own hands
and she has several motivations for doing so.
One, Ashley hasn't written an album in a while,
and the stuff she's been coming out with lately is drivel.
As she says to her colleagues, she's Ashley O, not Leonard Cohen.
Two, they need a way to recoup their losses from the Ashley Too dolls.
And the perfect way for that is a new album.
Three, Catherine feels like she's owed this.
She took Ashley in when her parents died and feels responsible for Ashley's success.
In her mind, she molded Ashley into the success she is today.
So when Ashley tells her aunt that she's breaking her contract, she takes drastic measures
and poisons her own niece to put her in a medically induced coma.
This way, they can access the creative part of her brain and,
using some new software, continue to compose her music.
Remember that Ashley gets her song ideas from her dreams,
so if they can access that, they're in business.
But there's just one problem: they can compose, but they no longer have Ashley's physical form.
Introducing: Ashley Eternal.
A breakthrough hologram technology which would allow for simultaneous concerts
around the globe, and did I mention scalability?
It's only when the doll overhears a news broadcast involving Ashley's coma
does it go haywire and malfunction.
The girls take it to their father's lab, hoping to fix it, but instead unlock its entire memory.
Apparently, every Ashley Too doll was instilled with the entirety of Ashley's personality,
but were given what's called a limiter.
The limiter would only allow the perky, fun Ashley image that fans know,
while suppressing everything else.
But now that it's been removed, the Ashley Too doll tells them the truth:
that there was no way her coma was caused by an allergic reaction to shellfish.
So the girls do the only logical thing and steal their dad's truck
to break into Ashley's house and find proof that her aunt is responsible.
Apparently, Ashley's laptop has a backup of her diary and will contain this proof,
But, as we'll find out later, this isn't the case.
Ashley Too isn't here to get proof of anything,
She's here to put an end to her own suffering, and ends pulling the life-support plug in her own body.
Now, this is interesting because it's almost as if you were to pull the plug on yourself;
it's Ashley's own consciousness in that doll.
As she tells Rachel about her decision,
"Rachel, listen, I know me, okay? And I know I wouldn't wanna exist even ten minutes in that state!"
But things aren't always what they seem in Black Mirror.
Ashley wakes up seemingly from the dead and scares the crap out of Rachel and Jack.
She wasn't on life support, she was being medically sedated in order for Catherine to exploit her.
They escape from Dr. Monk and speed off to confront Catherine at her investors meeting,
where she's unveiling Ashley Eternal.
Here, we can see some of the features, which include extended and
enhanced physical life, the ability to perform in harsh environments like the moon,
and the ability to control its consciousness.
Gone will be the days of performers getting sick, an AI infused with the artist
can manifest itself in hologram form and perform anywhere around the globe and beyond.
All that's needed is a dude and a motion capture suit, and you're good to go.
Oh, and costume changes are real easy and the girls come in like a wrecking ball
Totally crashing the investor meeting here Catherine knows the gig is up
We also get this little post credit sequence showing Ashley embracing her true self performing alongside Jack at the club
She longingly stared at at the beginning of the episode. She's no longer trapped floating freely above the crowd
We also get Kevin trying to sell his shitty rat
contraption and the two girls who were seen crying over Ashley's allergic reaction who aren't too thrilled about
Ashley's new look and that's the point. This story is about being yourself
Not what others want you to be now for a little bit of fun
Let's go over. This episode's Easter eggs over a telecast the report exclaims that Ashley was rushed to st
Junipers Hospital a nod to season three's Sam Junipero, which is also shown in Bandersnatch as st
Junipers medical practice san Junipero also deals with the idea of having consciousness transferred through technology
And st. Junipers is also where Peter Dawson worked in season fours black Museum episode on the newscast
We get several fun bits of Easter eggs in the ticker below like narrative creator still missing
Which is likely a nod to game design or Colin Rickman who goes missing and Bandersnatch?
although the timelines don't quite
Match up with that since that was said in the 80s so it could be his daughter who took over his legacy
And guess what? The name of Rachel's High School is
written in hi the song Ashley Oh sings on a roll is a rewrite of The Nine Inch Nails song head like a hole which
Trent Reznor gave his blessing for black Mayer to do Gervin Records is named after story editor David Gervin and the director and
Savitsky is the actual director of the entire episode
Continuing with Nine Inch Nails the song Ashley sings on her own here is the song right where it belongs now
I'd love to play a clip of that. But that's just a trip to demonetised City during the newscast
We find out the network is USN, which is likely the American spin-off of the British version. We've seen in Black Mirror
Ukm, and on the tikar below we get more Easter eggs
Like architec arrested on multiple murder charges a reference to Mia Nolan's character in season fours crocodile
There's also cited gembo Cher's jump on striking vipers release, which is a reference to episode 2, which I haven't seen yet guys
But I know striking vipers is the name of that episode and then there's museum owners body found in smoking ruins
which of course is a reference to Rolo Haynes who died when his museum was burned in season 4 can't forget tusk the rapper from
Season 3's hated in the nation who was a target of the hashtag death to campaign and get your cosplay ready?
Because we have Sea of Tranquility which was the name of the movie
The cosplayers were going to on the bus lacy Hopson in season three's nosedive
That's it for this black mirror ending explained in Easter eggs
If you like these videos, please give it a thumbs up comment and subscribe
I'm going to be doing a video for each episode this season
So stay tuned and if you like you can follow me on twitter at think story whitey until next time remember daddy loves you
Very much